do you want to see my new guy of the
week
it's not Drake it's not Drake sure a
week in my life as a 24 year old
bachelor in DC look at my life as a 24
year old bachelor in DC no [__] shot
man no [__] shot
[Laughter]
God damn it this is a week in his life
as a 24 year old bachelor in TC okay
guys yeah yeah just to be clear oh yeah
all right yeah yeah yeah copy all right
on Monday I start
engagement at work so I spent some time
building out my look before heading out
at night I made some chicken for dinner
and worked on some personal budgeting
while watching The Departed on TV before
bed it's a good movie on Tuesday after
work I watched a concert over the Navy
Memorial near my house before heading
home to make a new salmon dish I have
been wanting to try out and then closed
out the night with my weekly dose of Law
and Order
on Wednesday I caught up with one of my
colleagues for lunch at officina which
is adjacent to our office we had a
pretty full lunch where I tried their
spaghetti and meatballs and their sauce
was incredible oh good in the evening I
headed over to the Spy Museum for our
firm's monthly fun event where I focused
extra time on doing the simulated
missions they had to offer and spent
some time in the cyber security exhibit
we closed out the night with some dinner
at Falafel Inc this is 24.
this [__] Act 50.
we were able to brace the Heat and eat
on the water
to close out the week I headed to wonder
Garden for a happy hour event hosted by
a public policy group I'm a member of
where I was able to network with fellow
aficionados and here remarks from two
members of Congress about upcoming
housing policy oh okay yeah this dude is
a CIA asset
this is a [__] yeah
uh no he's just a government asset by
all accounts how so he just is I don't
know what I don't know what capacity
what agency but he's an asset yeah yeah
what a narc a week in my life as a 24
year old bachelor in DC
I like the Spy Museum
I also casually enjoy political rallies
I think he's a spy from another country
maybe oh he's actually Russian just
something like that
oh he's motorboating gang
she was motorboating
motorboat Nature's there
yeah he should have just thrown he
should have just tossed in like a crazy
like wild card in the middle of that
whole thing yeah and then I hit this
yeah this is like and then we hit the
strip club afterwards yeah
foreign
I just kept picturing just a like a
rough cut he's just screaming in his
living room
just like releasing some rage after that
I went and saw a concert in the Navy
Park
and after that I blew off some steam
Friday night I went out with some
friends I met a lovely young lady who
went back to my place I blew her [__]
back out then I kicked her out of the
crib and ordered her an Uber at 6am
I was just thinking get ready with me as
a 38 year old going to the Drake concert
me and my pregnant wife went to the
Drake concert and we realized people are
kind of young here
I definitely got contact high
what are all these steel compressed air
cans in the parking lot
I actually know that'd be a [__]
that'd be a hard Style Show yeah oh bro
exactly shout out little Texas man yeah
yeah you messaged me this weekend yeah
hit me up did you see firefest 2 was
happening awesome and I think we should
watch what he's saying his announcement
video oh yeah watch this video this year
we're going to be a bit more reasonable
we're we are renting out all of South
Florida
yeah what's up guys this is a big day
because as of right now fire Festival
two tickets are officially on sale it
has been the absolute wildest journey to
get here and it really all started
during the seventh month stint in
solitary confinement I wrote out this
50-page plan of how it would take this
overall interest and demand in Fire and
how it would take my ability to bring
people from around the world together to
make the impossible happen
but how would find the best Partners in
the world to allow me to be me while
executing Fire's Vision to the highest
level
in my first year I partnered with one of
the biggest and best TV companies in the
world to produce a documentary called
after the fire I've also worked one of
the biggest production companies to sign
a deal to produce fire Festival the
Broadway musical and finally today we're
announcing fire Festival 2. we spoke to
people as far away as the Middle East
and South America and ultimately we
decided that firefest so we're going to
be doing it in Iran yeah
it was coming back to the Caribbean we
were targeting fire stuff they're doing
it in the Caribbean again two for the
end of next year and in the meantime
we'll be doing pop-ups and events across
the world guys this is your chance to
get in this is everything I've been
working towards
they just cut them off they're like no
no I'm going
yeah I know you're going I'm for sure
going yeah I know you're gone I'm on the
lineup yeah okay
down bad I'm the only person they booked
yeah we didn't have any money we'll do
it yeah yes anything I'll do anything
you're gonna have any money for the
artist so um you're cool we'll put you
on the bill you're cool doing a 10
minute set yeah I don't play four songs
convicted con man welcome to a day
welcome to a week in my life as a 35
year old convicted con man bro New York
City fire Festival too
Chase Bank is looking at this guy
licking their teeth they're like this
dude's got potential yeah you know
what's crazy is that there isn't a
lineup or anything yet but tickets are
on sale
so it's like already another kind of
scam where he's like pre-selling tickets
or whatever like fund the actual event
which the whole thing it says backwards
again
this is sick I can't wait for all of LA
to fall for this again
every La influencer who moved from
[__] Iowa yeah
to fall for
what you'd like to not get tickets in
time you mean no to do it to be like oh
to buy tickets I already got mine so
yeah yeah yeah you bought yours yeah
yeah
so we like we checked all over we
decided we're doing it in Alaska they
should do it the same like as an art
piece
like make it look exactly like that last
one uh and have it be like at the fire
Festival experience
that you know what you're getting into
when you go there oh that'd be genius
right and then people defending it not
every Festival has to be tailored to
what you want yeah
yeah
genius yeah
like it could be like the anti Coachella
oh it's good [__] genius where it
sucks it just sucks on purpose yeah
yeah it's just the Caribbean
at the Caribbean Sea
wow where is it exactly this is the
Caribbean what do you mean it's just
there
just pull up just pull up tell the Uber
go to the Caribbean guys go see us pull
off dude
man I can't wait to see this guy [__] it
up again
a Broadway play
who is seeing that
don't don't people who like Broadway
like crying and rapping and stuff yeah
what do you mean I don't know Hamilton's
biggest [__] like yeah so if they're
crying rapping yeah
I guess if they did that with this
I mean all things considered it is kind
of the best thing for him to do
Billy McFarland right what else would
get you more pressed than this
which is the way you sell tickets yeah
like it's it's it's slimy but it's like
that's him yeah and obviously I feel
like this is a an obvious move sort of
yeah and people are gonna go and it's
probably gonna work yeah
well you're gone I'm definitely going
Cody's gonna go there and it's gonna
suck as he like it was awesome and then
line that up way better by Drake you
know Drake didn't rap perfectly in the
Box Seats in front of me in the box
seats that I purchased in an
air-conditioned room
with direct access parking and VIP in
and out so I was able to get home in a
record amount of time
didn't hold a candle to the fire
Festival